walfoot guenther beernaert il est
médecin généraliste à munich à celle vue
d'ailleurs votre routeur bernard bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on le
disait peut-être un changement de cap 1
dans la lutte contre la propagation du
virus en allemagne avec ce nouveau
projet de loi
les restrictions pourraient être
généralisé à tous le pays alors que
jusque là c'était géré région par région
c'est bien cela oui exactement
et si bien sûr comme il ya pas mal des
landes les restrictions c'était souvent
assez différents et personne savait
exactement ce qui se passe et ont pu
céder ce s'est créé un certain tourisme
vers les régions qui étaient punis belle
ibérique et je crois c'est un pas assez
raisonnable maintenant de mettre ça un
peu dans un sens et centralisée c'est
quand même pas grave si une région et un
peu restreint même s'il ya pas beaucoup
beaucoup de malades alors on le disait
là les politiques sont divisés sur ce
projet de loi
la communauté médicale elle est plutôt
pour en règle générale oui le la la
communauté médicale elle est pour
d'ailleurs lé pour des restrictions un
peu plus fort encore
mais bon il ya la lucky et d'un cas
comme anti des gens qui veulent
absolument défaite et libration des tout
bien sûr aussi les boîtes les gens qui
travaillent dans des restaurants cinémas
etc
il veut
toujours bien sûr gagner leur argent ne
pas être bloqués et là c'est les deux
groupes qui essaient de réaliser leurs
idées mais à mon avis bon je suis dans
la groupe médical et pour moi c'est le
plus important qu'il n'y a pas trop des
gens qui meurent et qu'il ya aussi une
certaine réserve dont le dans les lits
de soins intenses que ya pas trop les
souffrances parce que kovy ne s'est pas
seulement une maladie qui est finie
après deux semaines ya pas mal des gens
qui ont de suite chronique et comme
maintenant on a les vaccins et ça c'est
quelque chose de super bien la fin des
tunnels et avoir et dans deux trois mois
on a une immunité de la population qui
suffit pour que là vraiment avec une
banque hors sion sont peut offrir eux
réduire pratiquement toutes les
restrictions on en est où aujourd'hui au
niveau des contaminations des personnes
en réanimation qu'est-ce que tu es ce
que vous observez il ya une augmentation
ces derniers temps il ya une
augmentation d'ailleurs qu un peu comme
partout en france est aussi une
augmentation même si les politiciens ils
parlent de libérer de ouvrir et cetera
mais on voir les chiffres de nouvelles
infections les chiffres de incidence les
chiffres dont le dans les hôpitaux en
soit intense en réanimation il augmente
et ça c'est un peu partout et je
comprends pas très bien comme les gens
ils arrivent des dire ça s'est amélioré
on peut penser à libérer tous la seule
chose qui s'échangent et c'est les morts
et ça c'est bien dû aux vaccins on a
essayé en tout cas en allemagne de
vacciner les très vieux le genre dont
besson de répondre jean chroniquement
malades et bien sûr ça c'était là groupe
qui a fait le plus de morts
et là on n'a presque plus la moyenne
d'âge est descendu de à peu près 4 avant
que les 80 à 55
alors maintenant il ya les jeunes qui
sont en réanimation mais bien sûr il ya
plus de gens qui survit vous arrivez à
vacciner en masse
vous avez suffisamment de doses comment
ça se passe on se souvient le
gouvernement avait été critiqué pour sa
gestion de la crise abbas comporte ou en
europe
l'europe a essayé les baisser les prix
et ils ont marchandé jusqu'en novembre
au lieu de demander déjà des vaccins en
juillet août et comme ils l'ont fait et
en et terry's réelles et cetera
mais maintenant on voit
et si elle promet ces îles sont ténues
on voit que ont mille joint on a assez
de vaccins pour protéger une grande
partie de la population mais jusqu'à
maintenant tout est vieux et tout est
fragile
ils sont déjà vaccinés c'est pour ça il
ya beaucoup de malades il ya une
incidence qui montrent un corps mais il
ya moins de morts et la laj moyenne des
gens qui qui sont réanimation et qui
meurt quand même parce que ils ont deux
des maladies chroniques parce que ya
certaines risquent par le poids par les
ex par diabète maladies de coeur etc
il y en a assez de gens qui meurent et
surtout d'autres malades qui ont cancer
etc
ils peuvent pas et traiter parce qu'elle
aime plaît
hôpitaux ils sont plein avec deux
convives
il nous reste quelques secondes encore
peut-être un mot sur l'ailé vos patients
les allemands général ils sont
demandeurs pour être vacciné où il ya
encore une vous sentez une réticence
encore le plupart ils veulent absolument
se faire vacciner
par contre on n'a pas tellement de
vaccins de bayod take for their et comme
il ya des scandales avec astrazeneca
il ya au moins la moitié qui refusent
strictement cette vaccin d'astrazeneca
en plus ses conseillers que pour des
gens à partir de 60 ans qui limite déjà
là groupe quand on peut vacciner avec ça
alors j'ai bien peur que ce tracé n'est
qu'à ça va rester dans le frigo et on va
pas trouver assez des gens qui les
prennent et bien sûr ça manque
et ça va retarder la protection de la
population en général
merci beaucoup wolf guenther beernaert
d'avoir répondu à nos questions depuis
munich vous êtes médecin généraliste